type white guy into google and the first
picture you'll see is this and that is
me hi my name is reed cavner but you may
recognize my face from tick tock videos
about white guys tik tok profile
pictures people's linkedin profiles scam
pages on the internet online dating
profiles from dudes who are not me i
accidentally became the face of the
default white guy and this is that story
it started in
2018 i got a text from my friend lizzy
logan who is a humor writer and she
writes for the website reductress.com
and she asked me if i wanted to be in a
stock photo shoot for them reductrus is
a satire news site kind of like the
onion but with a feminist perspective
and so they write a lot of stories
about men or from the perspective of
fictional men and they always use stock
photos to accompany these stories and
kind of give a face to the characters
they're writing about and i was very
excited to get this text and i
immediately said yes i have a lot of
comedian friends in new york and a lot
of them have had the chance to be stock
photos for reductas and i was always a
little jealous like i wanted to do it
too and i just got this text out of the
blue from her and i went down to their
office and did it they took pictures of
me
on the street pictures of me in an
office pictures of me in a kitchen
picture to me with a group then
nothing happened for months and then one
day i get a message on instagram saying
like hey is this you
and they had finally used one of my
photos in an article where the headline
was
most guys just want sex but i would be
okay with hand stuff and and then there
was my picture uh
as the character of the guy saying that
so a few of the articles that they have
used my face for are white guy excited
to burn down the system and then control
the rebuilding effort this guy's excited
for kovit to end so he can start
touching women again i think that i want
people to understand that like i'm
playing a character these stock photo
shots that i took were not me because
they're a satire site and i'm a comedian
and i thought that it would just be a
fun thing to be part of so pretty
recently i was working at home i was
reaching the end of the day and i
decided to just like call it at 3 p.m
and lay down and scroll tick-tock with
my dog and i opened tik-tok and i had a
notification
and one of my tick tock followers had
just
mentioned my name in the comment section
of a post so i went and i watched the
post and the video was this asian guy
and he was making a joke about how he
frequently finds himself like hitting on
asian women to only discover that they
are dating white men and that's
disappointing to him and i was the
representation of the white man and it
was very surprising like i'm watching
this video like being like why of all of
the photos of all of the white guys why
me for this like was there something
about my face or what i was wearing that
made me perfect for this and then
something occurred to me was that like
oh redux is a popular site like i'm sure
they do pretty good with seo i wonder if
he just was typing like white dude into
google and just picked a photo and so
that's what i did i started searching
and i think maybe the first phrase that
i searched was white guy and right there
on the first page like number eight or
something was my photo then it was kind
of
amusing very surprising and so i made my
own tik tok reaction video i explained
what was happening and if i didn't want
to be
on the first page of google
for white guy
making a video about it was a real bad
move because the video that i made got 2
million views within the first day and
my ranking on the google image search
for white guy
started climbing to number two
after chet hanks son of tom hanks who is
number one because he coined the term in
the idea of white boy summer so then i
began seeing my picture in all sorts of
places i saw people on tiktok using my
photo as their profile photo i did a
reverse image search and found that
there are people on linkedin who i think
that they're scammers and they're using
my photo just because they like needed a
white guy to represent the face of
whatever scam they're running or or
maybe i'm just better looking than they
are and they thought it was an upgrade i
don't know i got a message on hinge the
other day from a woman who said hey
there's another guy on hinge using your
photo i got one comment from a kid
saying hey i used your photo in a school
project and it's like i don't know what
that school project is about and i'm
like he's a kid i'm sure it's fine but
any time that somebody is doing a google
image search for white guy
they aren't necessarily doing something
positive in the world and so i think
that's my biggest fear is
if someone needs to just go grab an
image of a white guy are they a white
supremacist are they someone who is like
maybe seeking racial justice i i don't
know it could be any number of things
but i'm just hoping that it's not like a
white supremacist
[Music]
you